les activités européennes d'alsace à
deux ans pour se construire s'approprier
ses compétences à commencer peut être
par ce qui peut sembler le plus évident
les questions transfrontalières stéphane
baudry bonjour vous avez assisté ce
matin à la présentation de la stratégie
de la future collectivité sur ce thème
concrètement que pourront faire ensemble
haut-rhinois et bas-rhinois avec leurs
voisins alors concrètement déjà ils ont
affiché beaucoup de beaucoup de volonté
parlant d'une seule voix les deux chefs
des deux exécutifs bas rhinois et haut
rhinois terminant les phrases de l'un de
l'autre ils se sont donc attaqués en
premier à ce dossier transfrontalier
avec peut-être trois grands axes qui se
distinguent la langue
évidemment l'apprentissage de l'allemand
l'amélioration des mobilités notamment
au dessus du rhin et puis l'emploi car
on sait que le chômage est bien plus bas
outre-rhin et en suisse que dans le
bas-rhin
concrètement il compte s'appuyer sur sur
des nouvelles compétences comme par
exemple la possibilité de recruter des
enseignants la possibilité d'ajouter des
heures d'allemand à l'école et puis la
possibilité de définir ensemble avec les
allemands et les suisses un schéma de
transport transfrontalier mais tout ça
ce sera pour 2021
ça laisse à peu près deux ans pour le
préparer végète klinkert en vous
attaquant à ce dossier vous choisi
simple le plus facile pour commencer
cette cette collectivité européenne
d'alsace bonjour non ça n'est pas le
plus facile c'est le fruit d'une réelle
volonté politique
le 29 octobre dernier nous avons signé
avec le premier ministre l'acte de
naissance de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace et le coeur de ce projet la
colonne vertébrale en est l'europe et
c'est donc notre priorité que de
travailler sur le dossier européen
l'europe au quotidien à travers cette
stratégie
or comme au bahreïn il ya également une
réelle volonté une grande demande de la
part de nos partenaires allemands et
suisses de travailler avec nous sur
beaucoup de projets j'ai à faire tous
les jours en tant que présidente du
conseil départemental à nos voisins
suisses et allemands sur de vrais
projets en choisissant ce texte pour
travailler en premier vous vers orienté
volontairement très fortement l'alsace
vers vers l'est ce n'est pas vers le
grand est en fait l'alsace et vous le
savez bien à pour bassin de vie le rat
supérieur nous nous inscrivons dans le
cas du rhin supérieur et le président de
la république a dit le rôle important
stratégique même de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace dans sera supérieure
une carte
voilà on y reviendra plus longuement ce
soir avec des exemples concrets
merci beaucoup stéphane et à brigitte
klinkert d'avoir été en direct dans ce
journal